[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we were just talking about
poker our favorite gambling games
dante yes what's your favorite game
you're a gambler you're origami again i
mean
you know i can hear my game on
everything but texas told him it's like
i met joe i wanted to tell this story
but we totally got sidetracked man
like on the last offer we got
sidetracked by the actual story which is
super weird
no it was off the record
but yeah it was i'm getting in trouble
by the way
teach your tips like check your phone no
i wasn't there
no no you forgot to put on an airplane
okay i was trying to do this hold on let
me double check i put it on airplane
mode
i'm on airplane i'm on airplane there we
go
no so um it was funny because i met this
dude at a casino right
and moronga morongo morongo and we're
like oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] dante and i
was with you know
when you're like oh she's a [ __ ] joke
that's right i feel like i think we met
before we need to
i know for briefly if he knows me i have
to pity like opinion
but
[Laughter]
i was with uh uh some of my um dancer
buddies
poetics periodic students and then the
manager of that group
at that time knew you or already already
was comfortable saying what's up
so then yeah he came up made the
introduction and he's like oh [ __ ] you
play poker i play poker two and then we
went to go
and um it was a really fun time because
it was like
all these other people so the so the
thing that people don't know about the
the poker world right is like you got
your super
degenerates in la like la city orange
county and then as you can see you know
those are the dailies right hawaiian
gardens go to hawaiian gardens
and if you're an la guy you learn
aggressive poker play right you learn
how to play hard and then as you go
out like into the indian casinos and
onward
they play much more conservative much
more safer
and we went in and we were like betting
we were doing some crazy tricks like
the pots were grown to a couple hundred
dollars and mind you they're used to
it being like 40 bucks or something like
that and it was this one little grandma
sitting where steve was
and every time she won she was like
super happy and every time she lost she
was so mean and everybody
oh [ __ ] yeah no poker face whatsoever
dude
but i like picking on her because i was
like man if you're going to be a little
[ __ ] like that
let's go and you're at morongo right
yeah
yeah my memory recalls that you're
pretty you're
you're like a cash game player you're a
pretty i love cash games i'm more of a
tournament i'm a tournament
why you like tournaments more wait
what's the difference okay so a
tournament has a definite
end and a cash game is just
it just continuously goes and you can
keep buying in but tournaments it's like
once you're eliminated you're out
so the so the game play is long
unlimited lives
yes but the the gameplay is different
because tournament because tournament
like
right in the beginning you're trying to
stack your chips as hard as you can um
because once you become ship leader like
you're able to have some sort of like
big advantage
but cash game we're just having you
could play as chill as you want and he's
been there
you're also building a character because
the longer you play the longer
people start getting cut out and then
but what you're representing
they're like where you can start feeling
what these cans these guys playing you
know the personality you understand
so like yeah tournament would be like
let's say you
you entry fees 10 bucks right and all of
us put in 10
it's locked in and you can't keep buying
more unless the rules
you can let you like twice or something
yeah yeah
and then it's an elimination process
like most chips wins
a cash game is foreign the winner of all
the chips the guy who ends up with
all the chips a [ __ ] ton of money with
all of it okay
is that like a safer way of gambling it
could be safer
but some buy-ins are like hundreds of
dollars you know and well the world
series is ten thousand ten thousand
dollars
yeah i have a friend who've made it to
final table you don't even have to be
number one but if you're at thai
final table you make the world series of
poker right yeah we'll see no you make
like 10 million
seven figures without even winning
at least a couple or winning that table
you get like to say you say the pool's
like
a million dollars and it's like the the
winner's getting like 500 000 but it
keeps getting
chopped up as it goes down to like you
know it's like first place second place
so it's like let's say the
the pod is like 10 million 30 million
whatever
then yeah they kind of divided up by
yeah did you guys know jennifer tilly's
like a huge yeah oh yeah i played rob
before she's crazy she's good
oh chris she's by the way the and liar
liar she's the bad mom with the huge
tits and she's like
i don't care about my kids like [ __ ]
them she sees that lady oh but you know
i love poker i do i do
too man but the one thing you gotta
remember about tournament poker is
different than cash game is with you
know at any given hand you can't really
win the game
because it doesn't matter but you could
lose the game yeah
so it's like anything that what do you
mean so it's like the best hand you can
have in your hand is pocket aces
and you'd be like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm
gonna go all in but if you're gonna win
yeah pre-flop but someone get three of a
kind straight anything and then
you're all out once you're out you're
out you can lose you can't win the
tournament
in this one hand nope but you can lose
the tournament in this one hand
right so you gotta so why do you like
your tournament more than cash game
because it suits my game better
your style of play my style what's your
style of play he's tight
and very i'm i i like to call myself an
honest poker player
yeah yeah he plays the cards and the uh
and like the probability and stuff yeah
well you know
yeah it's all statistics and probability
and if they say would
you play thousands the statistics only
work when you're playing a thousand
hands and it's hard to
like you can't bully with your chips
early on like there's just a flow to it
right yeah yeah yeah are you guys
talking about texas hold them yes
but i have to gamble on anything that's
the only place i've been playing this
new game called blockus have you guys
played blockus
no no it's like tetris chess
that's coming [ __ ] it's like
pictures it's [ __ ] the dopest game
now we've been playing we've been
gambling on that
how do you gamble that yeah because you
have all these little blocks right and
then whoever ends up with the least
amount of blocks or zero blocks at the
ends wins and so we go we play like a
quarter of a block so you might end up
with 20 blocks that's five bucks so that
everyone has to pay the winner
what we got i'll bring it in one day i
know you guys been doing some game
nights
it's like tetris chess oh [ __ ]
how do you feel about playing four
player four and this is something that
like you have a
uh you know poker like we we want to
play with everyone but there's such a
high learning curve because you got to
learn
this you can learn you learn in two
minutes and then you're like
and everyone's hooked last time oh we
should play that's playing
we gotta play it how do you feel about
playing
like poker with your friends nah i mean
it's just friends i love playing pokemon
but there's a difference of how you play
right oh yeah right
that's what i'm do you destroy the lost
boys regularly yeah
what do you play for hooks don't you
dare raise on me
i have a question um you know the other
poker where you have like
five cards five cards there's a bunch of
them on my pie guys my seven card stuck
or like the five card one they're all
there's something called the striker
isn't it five card stud i don't know
i'll put me back does texas hold on
poker
that's the best one yeah that's the best
one but no one played that [ __ ] growing
up we all played i played that growing
up
and that's why like seeing it come out
now i'm like or like you know we're
talking about it again i'm like oh [ __ ]
because i used to
play that all the time but there's like
50 different poker games but then like
the five card one
i don't know how to play the card draw
five card stock pocket would you just
take it out and then you could
change one of them and then family style
where you can pick all these with so
many different games whoever was the
dealer can pick the game
spit in the ocean that's fine grow your
own wild all kinds of we'd have crazy
dose but so don't you you know about
this
big too dude you're such a you're how
often are you at the casinos you think
hardly ever these days but there's
moments online but but because it's
weird because we were we were all in
vegas and we randomly backed into this
right
that's why it's a [ __ ] liar we're all
at the rio
we're at the rio and we randomly voted
caesar's palace
no that was caesar's buffet you guys
were wrapping up your buffet
meal and we were just sitting there you
don't go to the casino no no no
it wasn't real bellagio
yeah we were trying to meet up and hang
out okay i was there for the family
field trip i was there
yeah i don't think it was as coordinated
as you like to play it off
i mean i do like to gamble we should
take we can we do like a vlog and we
love it we would love it i knew you'd
like to gamble when you said well these
days not that often where i'm like we're
in a pandemic
like no one's really going i just wanna
poke a game like monday night
how much like uh like a home game yeah
one like 350.
okay you still play online
yeah i have like a monday night i got
money trapped into some accounts i've
never taxed my wife plays online every
[ __ ] day
she's filipino it's fake money it's fake
money but she's
she's honing her [ __ ] yeah i know but
she knows how to play she knows how to
hold him
this [ __ ] is crazy ain't nothing better
than a woman who could play some [ __ ]
poker
legit like nikki has like
a mathematical ability like i swear to
god it's crazy
it's weird because you actually see
people's personality in the way they
play you do
you really do i do remember i was just
thinking about this before i came out of
the bathroom is
remember come out came here one night
and we all play poker what what the [ __ ]
we had something i think we used to have
poker games here we got poker night they
had a whole poker table they got rid of
yeah we had a whole
drove out this [ __ ] place in the
middle of night we had poker yeah we
never used that pokemon i know i always
stared at it we
used it twice twice wait what happened
to it where'd it go
ask michael do you not play poker no i
play i just don't know what the [ __ ]
going on
but i play i can't wait you would love
it i'll teach you like
just like jk party teach me how to lose
to you no no
you teach but i'll teach you all the
stats when you look at you'll know the
stats of
exactly the how you know you'll know
everyone's stats the percentages with
how you'll win the hand or not hey
everyone today's video is brought to you
by
full sail university and full cell's
freaking dope
it's because they're a place where you
can learn how to edit
game make music make film so all of you
guys
that watch these videos are like how do
i get into the creative field well guess
what there's a whole university
dedicated to that kind of stuff that's
right and you guys want to know
a secret what i'm going to tell them
right now that
all of their old school classics of just
kidding films
full sail had a little bit of an
influence in making this
because we have here a full sale alumni
come on over here
casey chad
[Music]
[Music]
so they produce great talent not only
casey but i mean you guys know
uh our buddy wes was good you know he
hangs out with the king batch crew and
makes awesome
uh content and and and many many others
uh
have came out of this awesome school
to produce great works of art in
traditional and new media yeah so if
you're interested in
any of this stuff starting your own jk
but don't compete with us call it nw nw
then go to fullsale.com edu
off the record to learn more about these
things and scholarship opportunities
yeah because they have those
so you go there uh fullsale.com
off the record to learn more about these
things so you can get smarter and you
can make awesome music
and awesome films gaming all that good
stuff they can make
no way films no way jose fullsail.edu
off the record i'll see you there
sailing away
you know what be a fun game so this is
how you create poker like poker
is like mafia right like you're trying
to figure out who has what but
imagine this imagine when like let's say
i accused tiff
of being mafia she always but now i have
stakes
i go i have i'm a bet 20 that she's
mafia but then if i'm wrong now i owe
her the twenty dollars
so now everyone's accusation has stakes
so you can't just
outright just start blaming everyone you
should do that for [ __ ] jk party
like betting mafia you should come to
his jk party with poker night
i don't want to do i want to do a jaguar
party big ass pot in the middle i
did play monopoly for real money one
time
what [ __ ] monopoly how much you know
because we're not you stop you start
with fifteen hundred dollars yeah yeah
so we played
fifteen hundred dollars no [ __ ] way
to take off
damn how long you just came you couldn't
cash in your houses at the end
oh but it was uh of it was six of us i
was like
nine grand that's nine grand because you
know you have all that money in the
basement there too i know what the bank
but
actually the bank made money because the
winner is nine grand but the winner
walker was like 7 200 and
the bank kept the house kept eighteen
hundred [ __ ]
i haven't played y'all wanna try to do
[ __ ] that game you guys wanna try to
do [ __ ]
my biggest monopoly for fit for real for
everyone you bring 1500
i'm kind of in honestly that sounds so
scary about that that sounds fun
i know how to make it back my bit my
biggest bet was a 15
000 move oh my gosh on ethereum is a
game called ether role
called ethereum's complex ether ethereum
ethereum role yeah so you have to bet
ethereum to play the game
so i was using martingale method and i
would double down
even if i if i lost right so it's like i
bet one ethereum and then i lose
next time i bet two ethereum then i bet
four then i bet [ __ ] eight you gotta
wait
all the way to fifteen grand that's
crazy so i already had one
15 grand so you had a kids roll and then
i
started and then i got i started doing
martingale meth and i started to [ __ ]
it was like oh my
god i never got this high before i was
like 10 12.
and then i was like okay this is scary
as [ __ ] and i lost it i was like i'm
walking away
so i walked away dead even so i didn't
walk away 15 can a roll i lost 15k
that i had earned through like playing
this game for like nine days so you
how do you play this game yeah if you
play decentralized through the
blockchain you can play it the
[ __ ] yeah it was just one gamble on the
blockchain
for tax purposes i'm talking this about
this as a story
yeah it's basically like yeah you you
basically the the the idea is that the
house has like a
minimal advantage compared to vegas and
all these other games and so
like like it and you can look at the
code and like background background's
like of coin clips
right right it's like that so you have
to either bet
over or under like the number 50. so
you're like i bet it's going over 50 and
then like if you're right then you
double your money if you're wrong you
lose your money how many numbers are
there
no no it's over under 50. you know you
pick it's one to a hundred
that's one's 100 yes that's 50k yeah the
way i look at gambling too is like
as long as i play that's my lifetime
game right so
when i'm keeping tabs of it it's like
technically the way you win is you do a
50 50 game right or whatever like
like roulette or i mean not craps or
something you play
you win and you stop and you are forever
a winner
right but if you keep playing for your
lifetime then
at the end of your [ __ ] death bed
that's when you tally up
what if you've won or lost i think i'm
open
right now i'm saying you think you're up
yeah i actually have a tally
that's good you're right when you're a
real so i'm up 3 000
from the moment i started to gamble
because like you're starting to kill
your person
i've started a a gambling pile because i
don't chase my losses and then
i've done that right and then i would
come back every trip because i took it i
took poker series to the point where i'm
like
professional oh this is just poker not
including crypto or anything
i don't consider that gambling oh cause
i was gonna say what was that at two
months ago
no no no no no no no no no no i'm
thinking about a gamb
no no no no no no no steve no but but
you have mentioned crypto as a gamble
too
you said i say i approach it like a
gambler we're all artists so we're
already in the goddamn game
there's nothing bigger gamble than that
the way i see the casino
is unless i mean you don't have an
advantage it's a stupid play right
you're there for fun
the house wins every time look at those
big casinos that tells you they win
every [ __ ] and poker yeah you do have
a advantage but not really the killer
winners of gambling are the people who
find
um like so for example i know a
professional gambler who makes about a
million a year doing this right it's a
good job
and what they do is they know that uh
certain slot machines are the algorithm
is about to pay out when there's x
amount of dollars being spent
so it's like if you spend like about a
hundred thousand on this slot machine or
so
it's about to pay out and um
sell this information whoa and yeah so
there's a huge underground network of
this i see so the program is
underneath and then they sell this
information for like 200 grand or
whatever
wow you pay for that right and then you
get a jackpot of like a million
and then there's other people you got to
pay out because you can't always go into
the casino and this sounds like you can
get shot
this sounds like the monopoly game at
mcdonald's yeah i watched the
thing basically no one won no one won
but that's what he's talking about
oh they're giving away they're they're
they're giving away the [ __ ] broadway
you were giving away the broadway you
know whatever you would win
like i mean i don't get i parked so many
goddamn times never saw a [ __ ]
boardwalk yeah so you that's how you
went out gambling and beating the casino
you look forward to
it's not cheating you're looking for
holes
and it's not illegal you're looking for
the program that's gonna sell you
the algorithm that's not illegal that's
not illegal but
it could be wrong right so you're taking
a risk they're just pointing you
and they're saying hey this is probably
going to pay out in 200 000
that's wild yeah that's pretty wild i
mean i guess but what about blackjack
yeah so when people go in and try to
beat the casino it's very hard to beat
it but
there are people that have and every
single person that's beat it it's
because they find
these like this family they found that
uh certain roulette tables right
they have a lien to them and so more
numbers
because a human there and how they built
more numbers were coming out more than
others okay so the way i play play
roulette
is i move the ball in my mind
then you're you're cheating you're
cheating no no because i
you really try to visualize the number
like it's going to be thousands of
dollars
i'm going to the casino with you
explains how you train your mind to move
things this is what [ __ ] happened
this is how people lose i was
on the way what are you doing outside uh
australia to do a con or something and
then i
watched that movie which isn't captain
america when he was moving [ __ ] chris
evans
yeah but you know oh yeah that one which
one chat one
yeah something like that the one that
that we watched recently
yeah with the little girl in it yeah so
i watched push i fell asleep on a plane
to push and i woke up in australia and i
and i thought i could do that i
picked your [ __ ] dante on the
roulette [ __ ] table going like this
because
drugs involved no drugs
just a gambling addiction i was drinking
we were having drinks and i was with
these other actors and we're at the
crown casino and then i was like
i think i can move the ball dude that's
like me [ __ ] taking tests when i was
a kid
and being like that's the answer yeah
and so what happens is i go what do you
mean he's like
i don't know just i can't move the ball
and he's like you're drunk i know i am
but check this out
so i'm saying i'm gonna move the ball to
the zero the green because he knows
it's black and red yeah but then there's
the green one that's zero there's only
a double zero well in australia's only
zero but then
oh better probability so you do zero so
you i go
bet i'm just gonna bet on the zero and
i'm gonna bet on like three to five on
each side
and i'm gonna move the ball to the zero
and then i won like three thousand
dollars and they were like the other
actually this [ __ ] is doing some
[ __ ] how come you couldn't do it again
i do it every now and then i got but i
got to be the right amount of drunk
do they ever tell you you could do that
but you can't land an audition
oh so sometimes when you're drunk it
just jumps out of you comes to you
yeah it just comes out to me we need to
go to vegas that
that same night because i did i won like
three thirty three hundred that night on
the roulette
and then i played the worst game in the
casino which you know the worst game the
casino is
no yeah the [ __ ] the whispers i'll
rule that yeah no no it's it's the
dollars
on the wall and then they spin it like a
little like
a wheel of fortune type of thing yeah
and i want it two times back to back
oh my god they're like this [ __ ]
is moving [ __ ] with his mind
i said we need to get out of here we got
it i think we did it and it's because i
watched that movie push
nice i know push really stuck with me
too so we got to watch push and then all
of us go to vegas exactly that's
which makes me think it makes me think
that i could push my own thoughts on
other people sometimes
i don't know about it no because that's
literally what she does in the movie
oh really yeah that was her whole thing
how she like brainwashed him to believe
that they had a whole relationship
sometimes i feel like i'm gonna buy a
donut and eat it but at the end of the
day you know gambling
winning the money's fun but i actually
just like
the act of playing the game yeah that
part is fun yeah we're all addicts right
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i'm
feeling in the rush the hope
for me the action is the juice dude the
action is the juice i don't care if i
win or lose really i just like playing
yeah yeah as long as you're playing
the amount of money that you can lose
you'd care if you
put 15k that's why vegas loves us
because i don't care if i drop
a thousand dollars on a table because
the action is the juice i know but the
action is just but you man we went ham
with a one dollar craps table
oh dude we were treating it like it was
a thousand i do love crabs
i did learn a new technique the iron
cross that's gonna that you can
stack the highest degree
why do you need to do that if you can
just move it all with your mind yeah
well
i haven't figured out what the dice dice
is too many sides the ball
one ball balls has all sides one ball
you can't move one ball dice to move
them and then put them in the right
place that's too [ __ ] hard
i know i'm skeptical we gotta go and
find out i'm very skeptical call james
randy
you